[موسيقى]
ضمن فعاليات اسبوع الازياء الفارسي
للخياطه الرفيعه قدم جورج ارماني مجموعته
الجديده
وكانها تعكس رقصه خياليه ترسمها الخطوط
والاضواء والالوان في تمايل اهتزازات
ناعمه وتناغم وانشطار ضوئي مذهل مجموعه
تتراقص فيها العارضات في تالق انيق سترات
صغيره مرصعه بالجواهر وتنانير طويله
وسراويل سياديه مرنه وفساتين ضيقه في صور
ظليه ساحره اشكال ماسيه مستوحاه من لوحه
المحرج تخترق صفاء الاسطح باشكالها
الهندسيه الملونه
والفيروزي والاخضر الزمردي والازرق الملكي
[موسيقى]
حواف سوداء في زخرفه مرسومه على الاشكال
تنسى بجاريه على طول المظهر الجانبي للقطع
المحاكى الوجه
صغير او مخفي بواسطه وشاح من التين تماما
مثل التصاميم الداخليه من الغوكو في قصر
البندقيه روعه الضوء تمت مضاعفتها في
التطريز غير العادي والتي تخلق احاسيس
كبيره يمتد الماس على منصه العرض ضمن لوحه
من الالوان والاشراق تتبلور لتصبح حقيقه
واقعيه
[موسيقى]
في كل مره يعرض مجموعه يحرص جورج ارماني
على ابراز المراه بابها حله وكانها اميره
او ملكه تتمايل في ممرات قصر او تشارك في
بال سنوي او موسمي للتعكس الفخامه
والاناقه المثيره والمميزه العتبه الزاري
باريس